ونحييكم متابعينا الى نقاش الملف الثاني
تتضارب روايات بشان الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد على القوات الروسيه وحجم الخساره
لدى كل من الطرفين المتحاربين وبينما تقول
كيفن قوتها تحقق اولى ما كسبها بالتقدم
نحو باخموت تواصل القوات الروسيه عمليتها
الخاصه في محاوله لاستكمال ما اسمته تحرير
الاقاليم الاربعه التي ضمتها مؤخرا لكن
القياده الشرقيه للجيش الاوكراني تشير الى
فشل المحاولات الروسيه لجن هجمات مضاده
قرب بلده بيلاجورا وايفانوسكي هذا وقالت
اوكرانيا ان قواتها استعادت اكثر من قريه
جنوب شرق البلاد لكن ذلك التقدم باجمالي 5
كم لا يعد اختراقا للخطوط الروسيه كما
يقول مراقبون فاكياف امامها 90 كيلومترا
حتى تصل ساحل بحر ازوف وفق رويترز موسكو
من جهتها لن تعترف رس ميا باي تقدم
اوكراني بخلاف تصريحات وزير الدفاع بصدد
القوات الروسيه العديده من الهجمات
الاوكرانيه وبالالحاق خسائر فادحه في
صفوفها ما يدفع عن التساؤل هل بدات
استراتيجيه كيف تحقق اهدافها امن ان
لموسكو خططا دفاعيه لردعها
معارك ضاريه في بؤر قتاليه محتدمه على
الخطوط الاماميه هكذا جاء اعلان القياده
العسكريه العليا في اوكرانيا عن المرحله
الاولى من الهجوم المضاد الذي تمكن من
استعاده عدد من القرى من القوات الروسيه
وفق قولها هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه قالت ان اليوم الاول
من الهجوم المضاد شهد نحو 25 معركه بالقرب
من باخمت في شرق اوكرانيا والى الجنوب
بالقرب من افدي افكا ومارينكا وهي بلدات
تقع جميعا في منطقه دوناتسك وكذلك بالقرب
من بيلو هرفكا في منطقه لوغانس صحيفه
وورسريد جورنال ذكرت من جهتها ان هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد يحقق مكاسب صغيره بعد
الهجمات المبكره المكلفه موضحه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه صعدت بشكل كبير من هجماتها
بهدف اختراق الخطوط الروسيه حيث تستهدف
كييف الدفاعات الروسيه في الجنوب والشرق
لكن الهجمات الاولى كانت مكلفه حيث تم
تدمير اربع مركبات قتال من طراز برادلي
ودبابتين من طراز اليوبارت المانيه الصنع
كما تم التخلي عن ناقله جند المدرعه
فرنسيه ومركبه قتاليه امريكيه الصنع في
ساحه المعركه وفقا لفريق اوركس المتابع
لشؤون الحرب
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكوس
المحلل العسكري اهلا بك من ابوظبي نادي
الدبلوماسي والاوكراني اهلا بكم ضيوف
الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من السيد في
تاليف الجنين من ابو ظبي سيد فيتالي
مبدئيا حتى نفهم مسار هذه التطورات
والموقف الاوكراني كذلك مما يحدث الى اي
مدى اوكرانيا تعول على هذا الهجوم المضاد
لاسترجاع اراضيها والاهم الى اي مدى هي
مؤمنه بامكانيه تحقيق ذلك
مساء الخير يا مرشدين الكرام
اولا تلتزم اوكرانيا بصمت والهدوء
المعلوماتي في هذه المرحله يعني بشكل عام
يعني وفقا لمعطيات وزاره الدفاع تتقدم
قوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه في عده اتجاهات
وحتى نجحت في تحرير عده كوره وفي منطقه
الدنيا
ولكن يعني من وجهه نظرنا الدعايه الروسيه
هي التي بدات هذه الحمله الاعلاميه حول ما
يسمى الهجوم المضاده الاوكراني بدات
الحمله بهدف حشد الشارع روسي وناشر اخبار
مزيفه عن اخفاقات وهزائن مزعومه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه وفي السياق هذه الحمله
تظهر الدعايه الروسيه فيديوهات معدات
ركنيه متضرره ولكن غالبا ما تكون هذه
اللقطات اما قديمه او نفس الحالات ولكن تم
تصويرها من زوايا مختلفه على سبيل المثال
نشرت الدعايه الروسيه فيديو الضرب حصادات
اوكرانيه وقالت انها الدبابات
واحيانا تضرب نماذج خشبيه للمعدات الغربيه
وتقول انها معدات حقيقيه يعني في نهايه
سيد فجانين هذا الهجوم المضاد هي لعبه او
تسميه روجت لها روسيا ما رايك سيد ضيفي
يقول لك بان هذا المسار العادي للحرب وهي
محاوله لاسترجاع الاراضي لا اكثر ونحن
نعمل على ذلك بصمت منذ فتره ولكن روسيا
تروج روسيا تطرح بروباندا لمحاوله افشال
هذه الخطه
الهجوم المضاده الاوكراني او ما يسمى
بالهجوم المضاده الاوكراني بالفعل ابتدا
ابتدا ابتداء ولا يزال يتواصل وفي عده
محاور وفي عده اتجاهات اعتبارا من
جمهوريه دنيا الشعبيه الى منطقه
يرسون وزوباروجيا وغيرها
وكانت هناك معارك شاسعه
وتمكنت قوات القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في
اول يومين يعني قبل ثلاث او اربعه ايام
تمكن من التواغل في بعد الاتجاهات
على مسافه من اثنين الى ثلاثه كيلومترات
يعني هذا ليس هجوم استراتيجي ولا مكاسب
استراتيجيه وصباحا اليوم تمكنه القوات
الروسيه على اعاده سيطرتها على تلك
المنطقه وتردت
القوات الكريديه على الفرار والانسحاب
فيما يخص بالخصائص في الارواح والمعدات
هناك كثير من الفيديوهات وصور
على سبيل المثال بالامس تم عرض صور
فوتوغرافيه على صوره واحده هناك سبعه
مدرعات اوكرانيه بما فيها اربع كساحات
الالهام المضره على كعدت تفاصيل ولكن في
الواقع تبعنا كل هذه التفاصيل في نشراتنا
الاخباريه
يعني دبابه محروقه يقول بانها بروباجندا
روسيه وهذا ما حاولت ان افهمه من حضرتك
لماذا ترى حضرتك بان اوكرانيا
تخفي ما تقوم به تصمت على ما تقوم به
وحضرتك وصفته بالهجوم المضاد ما اسباب ذلك
لان
كانت هناك تناقضات في التصريحات الرسميه
الوارده من كيف بدايه قال رئيس
الهجوم المضاد قريب وسوف يكون
ناجحا ومن ثم غير وجهه نظرته او غير
التصريحات قال
لم ياتي الوقت لان نحن في انتظار
المعادلات الاضافيه التي تحتاج اليها هذا
كل مفهوم انا فهمته ولكن ما لم افهم بحسب
قراءتك لماذا ما سبب هل هو تراجع هل هي
مخاوف اوكرانيه هل هي عدم قدره على التقدم
حضرتك كيف تفسر بان يقال شيء وفيما بعد
يختفي من التصريحات وروسيا هي التي تروج
لها
كل المحاولات الاوكرانيه في خارق الدفاعات
الروسيه باتت بالفشل لذلك الان
يمتنع الرئيسكي عن الاعتراف بالشنق الهجوم
المضاد هذا لان
لا شيء ان يفتخر به
النقطه خلينا ناخذ تعليق من السيد فجانين
ما رايك في هذا الكلام
انا اريد ان يذهب المشاهدون حجم المهمه
التي يجب وضع الدفاع الاوكرانيه تنفيذها
للتحرير العربي الاوكرانيا فنحن يعني بكل
تاكيد يعني اليوم او بعض البكره بعد شهر
او شهرين سنبدا يعني التحرير ارضنا يعني
بشكل كامل ويبلغ يعني عدد قوات الاحتلال
الروسيه في الافراد في المناطق المحتله
400 الف شخص
1700 دبابه واكثر من 4000 مدرعه وثلاثه
الاف مدفعه صحيح وهناك مهمه كبيره سيد
فيتالي ولكن يقول بصراحه بان اوكرانيا غير
قادره على ذلك اوكرانيا تحدثت وصرحت بشيء
هي على الواقع غير قادره على اتمامه ولهذا
السبب تراجعت في وصف ما يحدث بالهجوم
المضاد
لا تزال روسيا تتمتع بالتفوق يعني عدد في
المعدات ومع ذلك نحن واثقون من قوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه ساعدت مهاره وشجاعه
جيشنا في تحرير منطقه وشمال اوكرانيا
ومنطقه وخرسون وستواصل اوكرانيا تحرير
باقي اراضي المحتله خلينا نمارس يعني بعد
الصبر وننتظر يعني النتائج
طيب نحن سننتظر سنتابع كل ذلك سيد سيرك
استمعت الى ضيفه هو اشار الى جزئيه عسكريه
مهمه هو يقول بان روسيا هذه الدوله التي
صنفت على ان جيشها هو ثاني اقوى جيش في
العالم لم تتمكن حتى من السيطره على مناطق
صغيره هو اعطى مثال مخموت تعلم حضرتك بان
الامثله كبيره نحن نتحدث عن 15 شهرا من
الاقتتال على الاراضي الاوكرانيه في ميزان
الرابح والخاسر من الرابح ومن الخاصر بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا بعد كل هذه المرحله
المعلومه انها كانت تعتبر كرمز
الصمود والتصدي وقال رئيس تكرارا ومرارا
انه لا يمكن انسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه من
بخموت باي حال من الاحوال ومن استولى شركه
امنيه خاصه ليس الجيش نظامي ولا القوات
المسلحه شركه امنيه خاصه
هي التي
طردت الجيش الاوكراني
الباطن من
فيما يخص
بالحصيله من
الفائز نعم
15 شهر من الاقتتال قبل بدايه الخاصه هذه
كانت اوكرانيا اكبر دوله في اوروبا
رقم واحد تتحدث عن المساحه لا مستحيل
بساحه بساحه خسرت اوكرانيا اكثر من 20% من
مساحتها
وخسرت اوكرانيا اكثر من 10 ملايين من
النسمه
كل ما
تقول كيف بان الهزيمه لروسيا قريبه جدا
هذا
كلام وهمي وخيالي ولا يمكن التصور بان
روسيا تتعرض لهزيمه في هذه المعركه نعم
هناك
احتياطات استراتيجيه في اوكرانيا خمسه
وسته تلويه بعدها في في
الاحتياط ولم تدخل المعركه بعد ولكن
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن تسميه هذا الهجوم المضاد
كهجوم مصيري
المصير ما يليه هذا الهجوم المصير ما ياتي
بعد احباط هذا الهجوم وهذا سياتي بالتاكيد
فماذا تقول في كل الحالات تقييم عام لما
يحدث او للمرحله التي بلغناها الان حضرتك
تقول بانه اولا هذه ليست معركه تقرير مصير
الهجوم المضاد هذا ليس هو من سيقرر المصير
وثانيا تعتبر بانه بعد كل هذه الاشهر
روسيا هي المتفوقه لانها قضمت ما يفوق
العشرين بالمئه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تعليقك سيد فديانين
روسيا نفسها تعترف بهزيمتها في اوكرانيا
وتعترف انها فاشله في تحقيق جميع اهدافها
في اوكرانيا وهذا يعني ليس كلامي هذا ما
يقول على سبيل المثال السيد زبول سيد
زيبول النائب في البرلمان الروسي وهو ممثل
الحزب الحاكم في روسيا يقول نعم نحن فشلنا
يعني في تحقيق جميع اهدافنا في اوكرانيا
اذا يعني شو ممكن يعني
بنفسها تعترف يعني الهزيمه يعني جميع يعني
ولكن جميعنا طبعا يعني نريد السلام
اوكرانيا تريد تريده يعني اكثر من الاخرين
الشرط الوحيد اللي بتحقيق السلام العادل
والمستدامه هو انسحاب او طرد روسيا من
ارضنا يعني المحتله
ليتحقق هذا السلام يقول البعض بانه يجب ان
تكون هناك طويله مفاوضات ولكن هل يمكن
لاوكرانيا ان تجلس على طاوله مفاوضات دون
ان تلزم الط الاخر باثر رجعي بان تنسحب كل
كل القوات الروسيه من المناطق ان يكون
مثلا انسحابه هو موضع نقاش موضع تفاوض هل
يمكن ذلك
لا ناخذ لا ناخذ باعتبار اي مبادرات او
دعواته اقتراحات قد تؤدي الى التجميد
الصراع او التنازل عن الارض الاوكرانيه
اليوم صيغه السلام
رئيس اوكرانيا وقردها الجمعيه لعمل الامم
المتحده هي افضل الصيغه للتواصل الى
السلام وفي نفس الوقت نحن على استعداد
لمواصله التحرير ارضنا وشركائنا مستعدون
لدعمنا يتعهد شركائنا بدعم اوكرانيا مهما
استغرق الامر
دعم اوكرانيا طالما كان ذلك الضروريه يعني
سنحرر ارضنا بالكامل في الحدود المعترف
بها دوليا عن طريق الانتخاب الاحتلال او
دفعه بالقوه خلال هذه العمليه او العمليه
التاليه اذا طلب الامر القضيه القضيه
مصيريه بالنسبه
مع الاسف الشديد
الحرب اخذت تابع
الاستنزاف
على ما يبدو
يدور الكلام الان حول التجميد التجميد مثل
ما قال ضيفكم في ابو ظبي اوكرانيا لا تقبل
اي تجميد ولا روسيا تقبل اي تجميد
السيناريو الخاص بالتجميد ياتي من واشنطن
الان تراقب تطورات ميدانيه في المعركه
وتنتظر الى
نتيجه هذه المعركه
ومن ثم اذا اذا فشلت القوات الاوكرانيه
فيما يسمى بتحرير وطارد والى اخره ومن ثم
ستضغط واشنطن على كيف بقيت تجميد النزاع
هذا وهذا غير مقبول بالنسبه
كل الحالات نحن سننتظر لنرى كيف ستتطور
الامور سنكتفي بهذا القدر من النقاش
اشكركم جزيلا الشكر من موسكو سيرجي
شاشكوفل محل العسكري شكرا
لكم
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات